this will balance life thing if you ever
want to do anything big in your life
there's going to be phases in your life
where it makes zero sense
if you're in sports and you're running
for a championship you don't have a
balanced life if you're making a massive
movie that could potentially win an
oscar or academy you're not living a
balanced life if you're deciding to have
a kid we've gone through four of them i
can guarantee you my sleep life right
now it ain't balanced there's nothing
balanced about having kids don't let
anybody fool you nothing about having
kids balance life so but having a kid
are you kidding me it's an incredible
feeling when my kids run up to me
priceless when you see a project and
then you look at it and it does very
well and people appreciate it you sit
back and say guys we really crushed we
worked very hard we had 16 hour days we
crushed it we did it together nothing
about it was balanced so yes
parts of it fine but if you want to do
something that you're proud of that for
the rest of your life you can talk about
and laugh about and think about it and
reminisce about life's going to be
unbalanced during those times